[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an episode called mother's
remote from a sci-fi drama anthology on
children spoilers ahead watch out and
take care
[Music]
is a middle-aged woman who has recently
been divorced from her husband they have
a teenage son together named pei wei
shuli is overly obsessed with her kid
and wants him all to herself she has
even managed to obtain sole custody of
pay way the mother and son have recently
moved into their new home a worker helps
shulee carry all the boxes his footsteps
seem to disgust her so as soon as the
guy leaves she starts to mop the floor
shu lee is an extreme germaphobe who is
obsessed with sanitation and feels
compelled to clean excessively while
dusting payway's room she finds several
boxes under his bed she brings a
suspicious one out and finds the
school's stamp on it she realizes that
her son has been using them to create
fake test results to hide his grades
from her in school payway is with his
friends talking about the upcoming
graduation trip
they have planned to sneak out of the
hotel room to go for a bike ride as they
excitedly discuss the plan a female
classmate approaches them and asks for
peyway's friend's jacket they laugh and
hand it to her sensing a romantic
relationship forming between them she
gives him a note asking him out on a
date making the guys playfully tease him
before returning home payway prints out
a copy of his fake report card he plans
to use the stamps at home to make the
card look authentic peiway knows that if
his mother finds out about his
shenanigans she will never allow him to
go on the graduation trip but still he
takes the chance when he reaches home he
looks for the box but cannot find it he
pretends to be studying when his mother
enters the room he sees that she has the
box with her a nervous payway doesn't
say a word knowing that his secret is
out she starts to scold him but he
ignores her entirely shuli is enraged by
his behavior and gets ever more furious
when he says he's lost his actual report
card peiwei is interested in painting
and doodling but she doesn't support his
hobbies in contrast she blames his
doodles for his low grades and refuses
to let him go on the graduation trip in
a fit of rage peiwei says that his
father would have let him go following
that shoe lee quietly leaves him alone
she works till midnight to calm her
anger then knocks on his door again when
he doesn't answer she goes to a
convenience store to get a cigarette
while smoking at the bus stop shulie
notices an advertisement playing on a
screen nearby the actor questions the
viewers if their children are
disobedient this catches shulie's
attention making her listen carefully
using the latest technology scientists
have created a remote that will help
parents make their children do anything
they want they can basically make all
the decisions for the kids without them
rebelling the advertisement however
doesn't explain what exactly the product
is moments later a man approaches shulie
who she recognizes as the person from
the advertisement she just watched he
asks her if she is interested in the
device
kids if you ever receive a sales pitch
this sketchy run run far away the
following morning payway wakes up late
and runs to the door after getting ready
on his way to the bus stop he bumps into
a man and apologizes because of this he
misses the bus and has to take a taxi
when the taxi driver states his son also
reads in the same school he realizes
something is odd peiwei is experiencing
some kind of deja vu because he went
through the same experiences the
previous morning when he reaches school
everyone is already in class he joins
his group of friends and asks them what
day it is they reply that it is june 7th
wednesday payway clearly remembers that
it was yesterday which freaks him out
even more during break time they yet
again plan to sneak out of their hotel
room on the graduation trip similarly a
girl approaches them asking for payway's
friend's jacket not understanding what
is going on payway this time chooses to
stay quiet after a long confusing day
when he returns home he sees that his
box of stamps is still under his bed pei
is confused but he doesn't want to risk
his mother getting mad again he stamps
the fake report card and shows it to his
mother who appears disappointed she
doesn't call him out for lying and
simply asks him to have his dinner the
following day payway is again late for
school he gets ready and runs to the bus
stop only to bump into the same guy for
the third time when he misses his bus
and gets into the exact same taxi as the
previous day he registers that he might
be stuck in a loop a logical assumption
since hollywood won't stop making these
stupid movies he runs to the school and
looks at the date which still happens to
be the 7th of june after school he shows
his mother the fake card yet again
however this time she doesn't accept it
she claims that she had given him three
chances to redeem himself but he hasn't
learned his lesson a shocked payway
looks at her in disbelief as shu lee
declares if he doesn't fix his mistake
he will be stuck in the loop forever
following that she brings out a strange
remote and presses the reset button this
turns back time for payway making him
wake up on the 7th of june once again
the remote is a controlling device she
bought from the stranger at the bus stop
it is used as a torturing technique to
make one's child obedient payway wakes
up and confronts his mother but gets no
reply she asks him to make the right
decision and not disappoint her this
time still peiway does the same thing
again after all he's a who doesn't
study and lies about it for the next few
days the loop keeps on repeating when
pei finally gets tired of it he hands
her his real report card delighted at
her first success she instantly puts
forward another obstacle for him shulee
knows he hates bitter gourd so to test
his obedience she makes him eat it for
dinner fearing the remote he does as
he's told furthermore she demands he go
to cram school starting the next day
this means that payway won't get to meet
his friends anymore but still he cannot
refuse to make him the best in his class
she plans to repeat a day 15 times that
way he can learn the same chapter over
and over again while his friends only do
it once on his first day of cram school
she makes him wear the clothes of her
choice for the next 15 days he continues
going to the first day of class peiwei
hardly has any control in his life his
only way to survive is to do as told the
loops make him suffocate but his mother
is too obsessive to understand his
feelings the twist here is that there is
no good guy and bad guy they're both
dicks such as life
one day after class he goes to the
school and meets his homeroom teacher
when payway insists the teacher agrees
to try to persuade his mother to let him
go on the graduation trip he arranges a
meeting with her and puts forward his
concerns about payway's mental health
but shuli is adamant about her decision
she thinks she knows the best for her
kid and completely ignores the teacher's
pleas
one day payway is in the library when he
meets a girl named chang fang lon she
also likes to doodle so the two
instantly get along they talk about
several doodle artists and promise to
meet again the next day before
separating after some days of talking
peiway skips his cram class and goes to
fanglon's home for a date he is welcomed
by her painter mother and musician
father they are the exact opposite of
shuli which is refreshing for pei wei
the kids go to the terrace and paint
using water guns this is the most fun
pei wei has ever had as they talk about
their dreams and aspirations feng lan
says that she wants to go to new york to
study the arts the following day shu lee
gets a call from payway's teacher who
informs her of his absence somewhere
else he and feng lon are enjoying their
date they go to a photo booth and kiss
but their date is interrupted by shuli
who has found them after tracking
peiway's phone she takes them out for
lunch and asks fanglon several questions
about herself when they return home in
the evening she demands pay way to stop
going to the library and stop seeing
fanglon immediately peiwei begs her to
let him have this one thing but she
stays firm in her decision seeing him
desperate for something that she doesn't
like she uses a special feature in the
remote and resets the loop pei wakes up
in his bed and runs to meet fanglon but
she doesn't recognize him he is
devastated to find that because of the
remote no one except for his mother
recognizes him following that day peiway
gets extremely sick and can hardly get
up chuli takes care of him to the best
of her abilities but he only gets weaker
he often dreams of playing with his
friends and feng lon on a beach but
knows his dream will never come true the
scene shifts to several years later pei
wei has grown into a man with a stable
job and high income he is dating a girl
named gigi and has moved out of his
mother's house shu lee however is still
very involved in his life and controls
him to some point her obsession with
cleanliness has passed on to pay away
shuli doesn't approve of gigi so she is
constantly looking for girls to set him
up one evening they meet for dinner
where she has invited one of such girls
named riley according to shu lee riley
has recently returned from america and
is looking for a partner she tries to
engage pay way in a conversation with
riley but he clearly isn't interested
after dinner the two are left alone
riley tells him that she is actually
engaged to a girl her parents do not
support her decision and trick her into
joining people for dinner like she did
today peiway laughs and reveals that he
also has a girlfriend and didn't know
she would be here tonight they talk
about her life in america when riley
mentions new york payway reminisces
about his first love fanglon he
remembers all the time he spent with her
like it was yesterday and still despises
his mother for doing what she did to him
after returning home that day he looks
for fanglon's name on the internet and
finds out she is an artist in new york
seeing her face makes him tear up
thinking about all the things he missed
in his childhood the very next day he
books his mother a flight to europe for
a vacation gigi also leaves for a trip
to australia when he is alone he goes to
shuli's house to look for the remote
however he doesn't know the safe's
passcode on her way to the airport
shulie realizes she has left her
passport at home when she returns she
finds her son outside her house with the
remote that she used to control him she
furiously asks him what he plans to do
with it peiway approaches her with the
remote but is hit by a vehicle midway
the scene abruptly cuts to the day he
met fang lon for the first time she
looks at him and smiles while peyway
cries overwhelmed to see her after so
long we can assume that after pei wei
was hit by the vehicle shulie revived
him using the remote many fans believe
since the remote hadn't been used for a
long time it was still set on the date
when peiway met fang lon hence when
shuli hurriedly pressed it to save her
son she accidentally sent him to the
past subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching